in a first the ceo of apple testified in
a groundbreaking court case
tim cook was in federal court in
california defending charges
that his company's app store is an
unfair monopoly
at cbs news technology reporter dan
patterson tells us that tech giant is
squaring off against the maker
of a popular video game those apps
populating iphones have been put in the
spotlight
in a federal court case in oakland
california where apple ceo
tim cook was called to defend charges
his company is ripping off the millions
of developers
who make the apps
the charges against apple center on one
app
a video game called fortnite developed
by epic games
epic found a way to bypass the 30
commission
apple collects for app purchases apple
then
booted fortnite from its store in a
lawsuit
epic argues apple's removal of fortnite
is yet another example of apple flexing
its enormous power
to maintain a monopoly a position echoed
by megan dimuzio
who runs the coalition for app fairness
if you want
your app on an iphone or an ipad you
have to go through the app store
period there's no alternative is google
guilty of doing the same thing
there are similar grievances with google
as there are with apple
however you know our developer members
continue to point towards apple as
having the most egregious behavior
in court yesterday cook testified that
the app store is not a monopoly and
forcing apple
to allow competing app stores on the
device would damage the
consumer experience and lead to
increased malware
the phalanx of lawyers for each side
doing battle all this week in oakland
underscore
how high the stakes are